pendant les 5 jours qui a duré
l'opération vous ne vous êtes pas arrêté
de fumer je fumé encore plus j'aime bien
le TAC je fume la cigarette et si le
docteur vous disait de vous arrêter
maintenant qu'est-ce que vous feriez pas
je F fa mal je le sens bien ça vous fait
pas mal non je F de paquet de Tabas par
semaine vous êtes en bonne santé tout va
bien oui tout va bien vous pensez que
c'est pas trop mauvais pour la santé de
fumer pas pour moi pas pour vous vu ma
carcasse je crois que je me payer ça
vous fumez combien de paquets par jour 4
par semaine depuis l'opération de
l'année dernière vous ne fumez plus non
maintenant vous ne fumez plus comment
vous vous sentez mieux ah ouii nement
mieux je tous plus le matin rien le
chiffre d'affaires n'est plus le même
ben oui monsieur au moins 40 % de de
baisse et depuis les premiers jours de
l'opération antitabac vous avez résisté
ah résisté jusqu'à aujourd'hui ça fa ça
va faire un an mais enfin il a fallu
tenir le contrat et maintenant c'est
bien terminé puisque je n'ai aucune
envie de refumer